я хочу подякувати нашим лікарям які
дійсно є не тільки патріотами своєї
країни тому що вони маючи такі унікальні
можливості такі унікальні знання вони
вчаться за кордоном але приїздять знову
в Україну для того щоб рятувати життя
саме наших
українців дуже хочеться щоб кожний наш
пацієнт отримав би таке лікування який
би він отримав в провідній клініці світу
в нас у відділенні є Ну ті умови які ну
відверто кажучи я ще вважаю що ми їх
заслуговуємо як професіонали а наші
пацієнти їх заслуговують як ті люди які
тут лікуються хотілось би висловити від
всього нашого колективу інституту рака
від пацієнтів величезні слова подяки
корпорації
Рошен особисто Маріні
анатонівні
[музика]